>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Valda Morris: Welcome.
I'm Valda Morris the curator
of the International
Storytelling Center here
at the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
And I would like to welcome
each and every one of you all
to our latest presentation
of our ongoing Benjamin
Botkin Lecture Series.
The Benjamin Series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral
history and culture, heritage,
while enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisitions' activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of the permanent collections
here at the library.
In additions, the lectures
are later posted on webcasts,
on the library's website, where
they are available for viewing
to internet patrons
throughout the world.
So now would be an excellent time
to turn off your phones [laughter],
so it don't come a permanent
record in our archives.
Thank you.
Located in Jonesborough, Tennessee,
the International Storytelling
Center
and its renowned storytelling
festival were founded in 1973.
And we are delighted to say
that the center's records
and historic recordings are
now part of AFC's archives.
As a person who oversees the
AFC's Storytelling Collections
and particularly as
the person responsible
for processing the International
Storytelling Center's Collection,
today I am especially pleased
to introduce Kiran Singh Sirah.
Who, from since 2011, has been the
International Storytelling Center's
executive director.
Kiran's diverse career history
includes works such as an artist,
curator, teacher, and he's
originally from the UK,
where he developed a number
of award-winning peace
and conflict-based programs
in British museums
and cultural centers.
His accomplishments
include developing folk-
and faith-based programs at
National Museums in Scotland
and creating several
high profile peace
and conflict resolution initiatives
exploring issues such as religion,
ethnic, and sectarian conflicts
in Scotland and now in Ireland.
In his other [foreign accent]
projects, he has tackled such issues
as poverty, gang violence,
and modern-day slavery,
working with refugees affected
by war and persecution.
Including social marginalized people
such as migrant Roma communities.
Kiran went on to lead the Helen
Keller International Acts Award,
especially disability acts
of the Glasgow's Creative
UNESCO City of Music.
More recently, as a Rotary World
Peace Fellow, he has focused
on the folklore of homeless persons
throughout the shelter community,
exploring how to bring together an
international development community
with arts and culture.
As a folklorist, he emphasizes
his interests in the power
of human creativity
arts and social justice.
And the notion of a truly
multicultural society.
Today, Mr Sirah will be talking
on the transformative power
of storytelling a social
force of social change.
Please join me in welcoming
Kiran Singh Sirah.
[ Applause ]
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
Thank you so much Valda.
That's a great [inaudible],
who wrote that [laughter]?
I notice it's being
recorded, so I've got a tissue
because I've got allergies
so I don't want to run.
I'm sending this video
to my dad back home.
But good afternoon everybody.
It's wonderful to be here and
before I start, I just want to start
by first of all taking my
hat off to the entire team
at the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress.
And to wish you all a
happy 40th birthday.
And it's also wonderful
to be part of your story
because it's also my
40th birthday next month,
so I get to celebrate my
birthday with you all.
I'd like to start off with
a quick show of hands.
How many of you consider
yourselves to be storytellers?
Okay. Great.
That's wonderful.
Thank you.
Where my line of work, I'm
inundated with stories all day,
every day, and I love it.
I believe passionately in the power
that stories and storytelling have
to bring peace, tolerance, and
understanding to our world.
I believe that we are
all storytellers
because we are the stories
of those that came after us,
those that came before us.
And as we all learn to listen,
collaborate, and engage,
and share our stories with each
other, all of us have the ability
to write our own storied script.
All of us in this room
are carriers of stories.
Stories are part of our DNA.
We are all storytellers, hot-blooded
believers in the promises
of what storytelling can bring.
We are dreamers, disciples of
tradition, past and present.
We are artists, poets,
administrators, curators,
and citizens.
Or like me, a H1B resident
alien [laughter].
But regardless of who we
are or where we come from,
we are all advocates of culture.
My name is Kiran Singh,
and I'm the president
of the International
Storytelling Center based
in Jonesborough, Tennessee.
But as you can probably
tell by my accent,
I'm not originally from Tennessee.
I am, in fact, a newly
adopted Tennessean and before
that a Rotary Peace Fellow
based in North Carolina.
Before that an adopted new Scott
that made, lived and worked,
and made Scotland my home.
And before that an English-born
Sikh of British-Asian,
Indian, and African descent.
Descended from Kampala and Tororo
in Uganda, in Mombasa, Kenya,
and the villages of [foreign
words] in Punjab in northern India.
Now if you're confused
try celebrating Christmas,
[foreign words] or Dewali
at my house [laughter].
I have been with the International
Storytelling Center since 2013,
but my organization's work
began just over 40 years ago,
when a local high school teacher
called Jimmy Neil Smith decided he
wanted to save a dying mountain town
by creating an annual
storytelling event
that he boldly called the
National Storytelling Festival.
Now that was a pretty
fancy name for something
that was literally 60 people
gathered around a wagon.
The stages were hay bales,
if you can believe it.
But there was enough magic
there to spark a movement
and something my predecessor likes
to call a storytelling revolution.
Storytelling revolution.
It kind of has a ring
to it, doesn't it?
Well around the same time there were
less quaint revolutions happening
in other parts of the world.
And one of them involved
my own family.
They lived in Uganda at the
time and in the summer of 1972,
one year before the first
festival in Jonesborough
and four years before I was
born, there was an announcement
on Ugandan public radio
by then dictator Idi Amin.
And he declared that all
Ugandan Asians had three months
to leave the country or
they'll all be executed.
Now that meant around 50,000
people, including my family,
had three months to
flee the country.
Many fled the borders.
My family left for Britain.
They couldn't carry much but
what they could carry was taken
by robbers en route to the airport.
But having left behind all their
possessions and the tropical heat
of East Africa, they arrived in a
small English town called Eastbourne
in the middle of a British winter,
and that was where I was born.
As Ugandan refugees,
my parents stood out.
My father wore a bright red turban
and a colorful African shirt
and my mother an even
brighter red sari.
Later my dad told me about
overhearing a kid tell her mum,
after seeing my dad,
look mum, aliens.
Meaning aliens from outer space.
And my dad still loves
to tell that story.
Now for the most part,
the vast majority
of people were incredibly kind
and welcoming to my family.
But there were some that
were not so welcoming.
There was racism, and it
existed in my small community.
But as a kid that's not
how you think of it.
I just knew it was hard to
understand why I felt so different.
Home was always a safe and
familiar space but whenever I had
to leave the house, I felt like I
had to be constantly on my guard.
It was hard to concentrate at
school, and sometimes I ended
up causing trouble myself.
But things started to change
for me when my head teacher,
in a weekly school assembly,
started to tell stories.
Mr George was an older gentleman.
He was white, pretty much
like everyone else around me.
He wore this tweed jacket and a
kind face, and he told us folktales
and traditional stories
from all over the world,
and one of them really spoke to me.
It was about a prince who gives
up his worldly riches and goes
out into the world
to explore the world,
and he takes two objects with him.
A cup and a toothbrush.
One day, he looks out and sees
a man break a twig from a tree
and chewing it to release these
juices that would clean his teeth.
And he realized he didn't
need his toothbrush anymore,
so he threw it away.
Another day he sees
someone bent down by a river
and cupping their hands
together in the shape
of a bowl to drink the water.
So he threw his cup away as well,
realizing he didn't
need that either.
Listening to that story, I began to
observe a world in a different way.
Not only did that story
help to paint a picture
of a world beyond what I already
knew or understood around me,
but it connected me to the idea
that perhaps the world
provides all the things
that we need to live in it.
That story turned my fear to hope.
And it helped me see
the possibilities,
where before I'd seen
the challenges.
It helped me see my own
family's difficult situation --
the idea that parents were
showing up in an unfamiliar country
with just nothing but the clothes
on their back -- in a new way.
They didn't need material
things to connect to new people
or have new experiences or
to remember the old ones.
And I began to understand
myself, the world,
and my place in the world.
And I started to see the outlines
of the story that I wanted to see
in the world and how I
can make that happen.
Hearing that folktale, it felt
like Mr George was
speaking directly to me.
And I expect other students, in
totally different situations,
felt the same way, but that's
the magic of a good story.
For me, these first stories
allowed me to grapple
with challenges then
and for what lay ahead.
Through story I learnt to
channel anger, frustration,
and anxiety into injustice
[inaudible] and inequality,
into forms of storied spoken
word and as a slam artist.
Because story is my tool.
Telling is my shield, my sword, my
passion, my inspiration to write,
to repeat, to shape, to
understand what I've heard.
When we look beyond divisions and
labels in the societies we live in.
When we think beyond borders
and groups and allow ourselves
to embrace the wider world.
We become international
citizens of the world.
And we start to refigure and
reshape our stories with others.
When I first thought it out
in museums, back in 2001,
I met an education specialist.
I gave a talk at the
museum I worked in.
At the National Museum of Scotland.
And he said the best way to connect
culture to the people was to break
down the walls of the museum.
Let material culture be free,
he said, and let people come
and take what rightfully
belongs to them.
Now the idea resonated with me
because here I was a
professional working
in a major British
cultural institution.
We had objects, thousands of
them, many contested objects
that could be argued as stolen,
looted, or acquired illegally.
If the British Museum were to give
back all of its objects like that,
it would actually lose
10% of its collections.
But this was my first job in
a museum, my role as a curator
of education was to help
present Scotland to the world
and the world to Scotland.
But to be honest, what
I was finding was
that many British museums often
conveyed imperial perspectives
on British history.
One such example was an
exhibition called Teas and Tigers
at the National Library of Scotland.
Reading the intro panel, it
described the largest uprising
against British rule
as the Indian Mutiny.
As a person of color and
also a part of an empire,
what was my position
on these issues?
Whose side was I really on?
And whose story do I help to tell?
I knew for a fact that my ancestors
were not mutineers or pirates.
They were proud people who fought an
unjust system and helped free India
from British, including
Scottish occupation.
And to at least 2.5 million
people, British citizens with roots
in South Asia, this was the first
significant war of independence.
What a museum should
essentially do is to try
to make sense of the
world around us.
And lead us back outside,
with a greater
or empathetic understanding
of the world we live in.
Not just our nation
but our changing world.
It's amazing how personal
paths and new directions
and world events coincide.
Soon after I started my
role, the world changed.
We sat round the TV and
watched Twin Towers collapse.
Soon after a local mosque and a
local synagogue were firebombed.
Some people were trying to stamp
out difference by attacking places
of worship at the heart
of community.
Soon after, the curator
of the Islamic collections
and I received a letter
from a gentleman
from the Scottish Muslim community
concerned about what was happening.
He asked how we in the
museum could respond?
So we took out the Yellow
Pages and called every place
of worship in [inaudible].
We invited imams, priests, rabbis,
Catholics, Protestants, Muslims,
Sikhs, Buddhists, and Baha'is.
Six months later, a single event was
created through a festival format
to explore faith and belief and
identity in the 21st century.
Where people of faith and
secular traditions stood side
by side and told their stories.
Coptic Christians sang songs
of resurrection in Arabic.
Sikhs wore the Scottish Sikh tartan
and performed traditional
bhangra with Scottish bagpipes.
And Jewish Scotts performed music
that combined Scottish
Celtic and Klezmer tradition.
And in the way that humor
and meaning often coexist,
they named their band
Celtica Shmeltica.
[ Laughter ]
In that one single event, on
that day, six months after 9/11,
6,000 people of diverse faiths
and backgrounds decided
to come together.
To stand shoulder to shoulder.
To use arts, cultures,
and personal storytelling
as a powerful expression
of community solidarity
at such a time of difficulty.
That experience helped me to
realize that if you work in culture,
in whatever position, you're
a cultural diversity officer.
It's not a choice.
It's a responsibility.
This realization informed [phonetic]
my work over the next few years,
as I was appointed as a
public program curator
for Glasgow City Museums
and Culture Services.
Tasked to tackle social justice
issues in a city that has one
of the highest cluster of child
poverty in Europe, 360 gangs,
and where the average
life expectancy for a man
in the East End is
just 55 years old.
In a city, within a nation,
riddled with a complex history
of sectarian and ethnic division.
It also involved cultural
connections
through developing storytelling
approaches to societies emerging
from conflict, with colleagues
from Belfast in Northern Ireland,
as part of the peace and
reconciliation process.
I was a first generation
immigrant leading a program
that addressed a conflict
between Protestants
and Catholics, white-on-white
violence.
But as an outsider, as a brown
Asian, English-born Sikh living
in Scotland of English,
Indian, and African descent.
I was able to use storytelling
and my own story
to communicate the connection
between racism I experienced
as a kid to the sectarian divisions
I was witnessing as an adult.
Our projects evoked memories.
I used stories actively collected
from people who were affected
by the sectarian troubles.
And when these participants,
including individuals, communities,
and the wider culture
sector, museums and libraries,
arts organizations, with support
from political leadership,
began to invest and
recognize the value
of the storytelling process
in healing community.
We were able to collectively
build an effective community model
that has helped to envision
a new 21st century identity.
Not to ignore the past, but
to reveal it in new ways
and as part of a global community.
These stories were the base of
connections and relationships,
with community leaders,
ex-paramilitary groups,
territorial gang members,
politicians, police officers,
people of all different faiths.
To not only collect and tell stories
but to encourage them
to tell theirs.
What might be seen as a mundane
everyday story also offered powerful
ways to explore and thread stories
together, like the Scottish saying.
There are many threads
of this tartan.
Enabled important discussions
within a safe environment.
Storytelling offers a search for the
common ground and a place to find
that important meeting space.
To allow people to seek freedom
by starting to be free in our mind
and igniting our imagination.
Envisioning the world without
conflict is hard to do.
But through story, we can
paint a picture of a world
for ourselves and for others.
That is possible.
This is a process that can
take place between two people,
two communities, or two countries.
It can scale up.
It can scale down.
But this doesn't always
mean it's easy.
Using the arts takes
a level of thick skin
and conviction in our art form.
The first time I tried to bring in
two rival gangs in a museum space
to share their stories, they broke
out into an all-out
fight with each other.
But with commitment to building
community we tried again.
And with specialist support
from partners and city leaders
that saw the full potential
of storytelling,
including social workers,
community development officers,
police officials.
We developed ways in which
fostered story-based relationships
that continue to be used to this
day in citywide gang and peace
and community reconciliation
programs.
Models that are now being shared and
storied approaches in building peace
in the Middle East between Arab,
Israeli, Muslim, Christian, and Jew.
The approach was to see art,
culture, and creativity,
the process of story-making, not
as a tool to conquer or divide
but instead as a way to heal, to
come together to form community.
To have a voice.
To impart wisdom, sometimes ancient
wisdom through the tales we tell.
To follow a belief that in
fact we are all storytellers.
It's just about what type of
storyteller we want to be.
And that humble approach
led to big things.
The program we started is now
recognized by UNESCO, the Scottish
and Northern Ireland
governments, and is now has had
around 90,000 people
that have participated
in to tackle bigger
[inaudible] sectarian
and ethnic divisions, gang violence.
It's recognized by her Majesty's
Inspectorate for Education.
From the time when humans
picked up colored rocks
and etched visual pictographs
onto cave walls to the day
when NASA scientists inscribe
the visual human story
onto a pioneer space probe and
sent it out into the universe,
humans have told stories.
Storytelling offers us a way to
connect to other ways of life.
To the organic world, with
the forest mountains and seas,
in which our tales take place.
To the walls in libraries
and corridors of our museums,
our churches, our mosques,
our synagogues,
and other places of worship.
As a museum professional living in
Scotland since 2001, my colleagues
and I, around 2004, were
looking at how we could plan
to mark the 2007 bicentennial
year commemorating the abolition
of the British slave trade.
It was an important year.
Especially as I was
now living in Glasgow,
also known as the Second
City of the empire.
But for whom many people did not
realize was built on the back
of transatlantic slavery.
In 2004, I got to hear Lonnie Bunch,
and we invited him to Scotland
to speak at the UK-wide
museums conference.
At that time he was the president
of the Chicago Historical Society
and now, of course, the thinker
behind the new African-American
Museum being built
on DC's museum mall.
He said one cannot tackle
racism without grappling
with the legacies of slavery.
Yet few want to actually discuss it.
I was inspired by his words.
I realized that, as a person
of color and as a product
of empire that, I was
in a unique position
to facilitate those discussions.
I wanted to take what people
think as two opposing sides
of a conversation and
put them into dialogue.
Lonnie Bunch helped
to spark an idea.
We couldn't literally return these
objects to their rightful owners,
so we did the next best thing.
An invitation went out to invite
the members of the African diaspora
to interpret those objects instead.
Many of those objects
from museum collections
that had been historically or
been collected and interpret
through only Western institutional
Eurocentric structures.
An African Voices Exhibition
sought to reinterpret these objects
from first person narratives of
artists and poets and musicians,
refugees and members of the 30,000
or so African Scottish
diaspora community.
The project itself was an attempt,
for some of us on the inside,
to relinquish institutional control.
By provoking diverse interpretations
of the esthetics of
cultural property.
This work challenged the idea
of static culture and sought
to utilize contemporary
traditions drawn from African
and Caribbean folk traditions.
Including developing a
Glasgow Haitian voodoo alter,
a Rastafari reggae sound system,
and a commission of new artworks
for the museum collections on
themes of products of slavery.
By working with artists
of mixed British
and African-Caribbean heritage.
[Inaudible] Ford was one of those
artists that was commissioned
to respond to the yearlong program.
An artist of mixed
Barbadian and British descent,
she used her own body, her own
story, as someone of mixed heritage
to explore herself as an artist,
as a woman, as a legacy of slavery.
Ford's installation The Shadow
of the Object Fell Upon the Ego
used photography and sculptures
to explore identity and loss by
enacting the experience of slavery
as a violent suppression
of identity.
She created a series of
powerful installations
which included a masked self
portrait wearing a slave mask.
Taken from the museum's
collections originally used
as a form of punishment.
Ford described her artwork
as symbolizing the human cost
of the slave trade and the
prejudice that remains today.
There was only so far we
could go without breaking
down the walls of the museum.
But we could utilize the
museum as the object itself.
As a cultural space to
challenge racism and other forms
of crimes against humanity.
And how we could that
by unpacking how much
of Scotland made its
fortune on the back
of what many referred
to as tobacco slavery.
By encouraging us and
others to listen
for what I believe is the most
important cultural artifact
for any museum.
People. By incorporating
diverse and uncomfortable stories
and presenting how much of
Scotland's empire was in fact built
on the blood and sweat of
people that were once enslaved.
And how that legacy remains
with us today in various forms.
As cultural advocates, as
curators, as festival coordinators,
as public administrators.
It's vital that we gather
and assemble people's stories
to help our audience
listen in new ways.
As institutions of culture, it's
important that we share history,
in all its multiplicity, not
shape it into tiny narratives.
Harnessing the power of storytelling
to build a better world is not easy,
but I believe it's an
idea worth cultivating.
We want to empower people all over
the world to tell their stories
and to hear about other
people's stories.
To really listen.
Because when we think about it,
it's an art where you don't
need special equipment
or costumes or anything really.
And like Mr George's story had
taught me as a kid in school,
you don't even need a toothbrush or
a cup because the world provides you
with everything you need.
In my work and in my life,
I'm incredibly fortunate,
at the local level
to go into schools
and to help classrooms truly
understand this country's remarkable
cultural heritage.
And to work with healthcare
providers, to use story to connect
with their patients and
to help foster healing.
On a global level, I get to work
with key partners and collaborators
to help spread that
storytelling revolution.
Places like the Smithsonian
Institution, NASA,
the National Endowment for the
Arts, the Google Cultural Institute,
the Desmond Tutu Peace Foundation,
and the United Nations,
and many others.
And to work with our friends here
at the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress,
to help preserve
and digitize years'
worth of archives.
To promote storytelling, not
only as a traditional folk art
but to further it as a
contemporary practice.
And through our connection
we've a network
of Rotary World Peace Fellows.
We get to support groups and
communities around the globe,
such as the indigenous
communities of the Amazon,
and help empower marginalized people
to share their stories
with the world.
And why do we do that?
We do it because stories matter.
And I believe they matter a lot.
Through storytelling and, in my
work, I have seen how we can give --
if we can, we give it a go.
We can give precedence to
historical accountability.
To offer healing and reconciliation
to the oppressed and the afflicted
in ways that open heart of
listeners and enable us to share
and embrace social change.
And think about the connection
between social justice,
community building, activism, and
across arts and cultural alliances.
In my work, I've seen how we can
use storytelling to unravel some
of our underlying societal
challenges and the foundations
for prejudice that exist today.
How the voices of those sidelined
from history refuse to conform,
to be beaten down by those
with power over them.
How the small but powerful defiant
acts across time became work chants,
quilt makers, folk tellers, graffiti
artists that told visual stories
on subway trains, and
was used to empower
and form communities of their own.
Or those that managed to put ink
to paper or how artists turn paper
to pulp to those that scribe and
scratched and carved story circles
into rocks or circled
rocks into sand.
To those that turned stories from
the margins of society and learned
to play lead guitar in a
band and gifted the world
with Delta Mississippi or Chicago
Blues, the slam poet, [inaudible],
the Appalachian Ballad, [inaudible]
to protest [inaudible]
or Indian song.
Because when we think about
it, we cannot tackle racism
without unpacking the legacies
of slavery and oppression
in our modern day institutions.
When we think about it,
we cannot tackle sexism
without unraveling the way
that gender has been told
in the stories we've
been told all our lives.
When we think about it, we cannot
tackle bigotry without looking
at the stories of our
historical shared and global past.
And when we really think about
it, we cannot tackle violations
of universal human rights
without listening to the stories
of all those that have been
stripped of their human dignity.
One story from Ferguson [phonetic].
One story from Baltimore.
One story from Charleston,
South Carolina.
Pull these stories together and
collect we shape the narrative.
The narrative that builds the
movement and ultimately use story
to promote the idea that telling
stories matter because the Arc
of [inaudible] universe is
long but bends towards justice.
As one great civil rights leader
that stood in 1963 on the steps
of the Lincoln Memorial once said
a leader that truly knew the power
of story to inspire change.
Our stories help us as
we refigure, reshape,
and redefine our flexibility
identities.
Moving from place to
place, city to city,
country to country, to
form new communities.
When someone asks you what's your
story, you can reply which one?
Because all of us stem from
traditions that span thousands
of years to [inaudible] beginnings.
We all have stories to share
from the wisdom of folk
and traditional tales that
we carry from our families,
our tribes, our traditions.
The stories that speak of
40,000-year-old civilizations
from Africa, Asia, Europe,
and other parts of the world,
to the indigenous stories
all across this nation
to the stories of this place.
We have entered an era of
conflict that is taking new forms
and spreading in ways that
are outstripping the power
of the international
community to respond.
As ISIS spreads across the
Middle East, and we see Ebola
in rural West Africa, and
conflict destabilize Ukraine.
And here in the US, hate speech and
its consequence effects causing harm
to the idea of living
in a harmonious society.
As some of these factors harness the
power of story to join young people
into their dangerous ideology,
it is clear that we need
new conceptual lenses
and creative approaches
for how we can think
about the way we can collectively
build peace, mutual respect
and understanding,
and prevent conflict
from taking hold in our communities.
So not to only reveal
stories that matter
but also in places that matter.
Such as the many cultural arenas
such as museums and libraries,
national storytelling festivals,
that present the stories
of who we are, where we come from,
and importantly, where we're going.
We can never underestimate the power
of using our stories when we know
that a world of peace comes
from a state of empathy,
a state of belonging, shared notions
of joy, happiness and suffering,
all of which are fundamentally
part of the human condition.
To deconstruct the stories that
are destructive and enable us
to transform stories
into the constructive,
even if in that very moment
it's hard to see that potential.
I've learnt, however, that sometimes
in tragedy, there are small seeds
of hope that give rise to
new stories of opportunity.
After 9/11 in New York
City, when all visits
to visit attractions
declined, apart from one space.
The Islamic galleries of the New
York City Metropolitan Museum.
Why? Because humans
are curious beings.
We want to seek out the
truth for ourselves.
We are smart because we
have a desire to learn
about cultures we hear
about in the news,
so that we may form
our own opinions.
That's why finding
diverse and creative ways
to invent stories [inaudible] of
other people's lives is important,
and it's also why one of
the most popular museums
in this nation is the
National Holocaust Museum.
We don't go there to be entertained.
We go there because we're
trying to understand and grapple
with the story of who we
are, as one human family.
And how we, as humans, on one hand,
can be so incredibly destructive.
But how we can also perhaps learn
to shape our common human desire
to live in a peaceful
and conflict-free world.
And that's part of the reason I
wanted to share my story with you
because I think this work of
telling stories is important,
at the level of the individual
and not just the institution.
I was born in England.
My mother was born in
Kenya, my father in India,
and my brother in Uganda.
I have this longtime belief
that not only is my family
like a mini-United Nations,
but we are all storytellers.
We keep the old traditions alive,
but we're always finding new ones.
From as long as I can remember we
have drawn from our experiences,
our global traditions, and
cross-cultural thinking.
Stories are always crossing borders.
I've spent the first part of my
career in Scotland and now here
in the United States
with my own stories
and the stories I've
inherited from my family.
And there are many ways we can
do that through personal story,
through folktale, pieces of history,
and other forms we haven't
even thought of yet.
The stories past to me became
my vehicle to know that love
and hope will always conquer hate.
And that the business of the world's
most ancient art form, storytelling,
has the potential and power to
make a difference if used wisely.
I'm the proud son of refugees.
But I'm also part of the immigrant
community that has a great fortune
to make England, Ireland,
Spain, Scotland, North Carolina,
and now East Tennessee my home.
But in the way we might craft for
ourselves a sense of home, identity,
and belonging in the ways we know
how, we can also use our stories
to reach our full artistic
and creative potential
to cross boundaries of
ethnicity, race, and social class.
To listen to courage and voices
vexed about social apartheid.
And use our stories to
put the dream, desire,
and struggle of what it
means to be human into words.
To help us all build
a collective, diverse,
and plural society
that we all wish for.
In December last year, I was in
Washington, DC, co-leading an arts
and peacebuilding program at one
of our Smithsonian
Institution partners.
On my last full day there,
I carved out some time
to walk alone through
this great city.
It was quickly getting
dark, but before moving
to my final destination that
evening, I took a moment
to stand still on the
Washington Monument Hill
with the Lincoln Memorial behind me
and the Capitol Hill
way out in front.
Streams of airplane dust lined the
sky as I bent my neck backwards
to get in a view of
the emerging night sky.
And I waited there until
the sun began to set
over these magnificent
historic buildings.
Another day like thousands
of others of life and love
that this city has been witness to.
Standing there [inaudible] cold, I
looked out at the National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture,
currently under construction.
And I thought back to
that speech in 2004,
when I got to hear its
founder, Lonnie Bunch,
give that inspiring speech at
museum conference in Scotland.
And I thought back to what
he said about the value
of using all our cultural
spaces, all our peoples
to help society unpack and wrestle
with our societal challenges.
Before I came to the United
States, I had often thought
that America's immigration
story began at Ellis Island.
This was at the forefront of what
I'd been told and what I learned.
But after being in this country
and having had a chance to listen
and connect with others, I also know
that for 40% of people that descend
from enslaved people, an American
story came through the ports
of Charleston, South Carolina.
Telling stories is not solely about
a single place or a single tradition
but something that connects with
something much more profound.
It plays a crucial role in binding
and helping communities to flourish.
Things that are essential to help
us understand how we can improve
and better our world.
Museums, as the one under
construction, I think will help all
of us to think about how a museum
could help people not just hearing
new stories about American history
but hear the stories
that already exist.
That have often sat on the
margins and are thankfully slowly
but surely becoming part
of mainstream culture
and shaping the way that we think.
Because diversity and true
multiculturalism [inaudible]
about the integration
of diverse ideas.
We cannot change a
narrative by ourselves.
But by telling our
stories we can contribute
to a plurality of viewpoints.
To help build new narrative
arcs that bend towards justice.
By telling our stories as a force
to shift our minds
and excite our world.
To challenge the status quo.
And when necessary, kick a good
old mighty storm for a story,
but most importantly, we can use
storytelling to build bridges.
We need to do with
others, with ourselves,
and others that share
beliefs in equality for all.
I'm here today to share
an important message.
That each and every one
of us is a storyteller.
As storytellers we walk into
the hot winds of the world
and we pull our stories from
the heart, from our blood,
for the ones before us that
poured their stories into us.
We all have the opportunity
to use our stories in big
and small ways that are important.
We can use them to connect
with our families, our friends,
our coworkers, and our communities.
We can use stories as a binding
force whenever there is conflict
in the world because we
can all be the stories
that we want to see in the world.
And we can help others,
too, just by listening.
Because the power of story will
be with you wherever you go.
Because when it comes down to it,
to tell a story is an act of love,
that I believe, matters
to the world.
Thank you all for listening.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
How long was that [laughter]?
So I'm actually -- sorry?
So I'm actually very open to any
questions that you might have.
Please don't make them too
difficult or use really long words.
But I'm open to any questions.
And it's really nice to see so
many friends in the audience.
We've got National Endowment for
the Arts, Spoken Traditional Arts.
We've got the Smithsonian
Institution.
We've got Patty from
Journal of American Folklore.
We've got folklorists
and all sorts of people.
And many of you storytellers.
So anything that goes, ask anything.
I'm not a US citizen, so I can
leave anytime [laughter], right?
Danielle. She was my
professor, by the way.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: There
was many different levels,
and one of the things that I --
I'm trying to fit this into a kind
of good answer for you but I'm also
thinking about other things that --
when I first came to the country,
there was a leading folklore
[inaudible], Elaine [inaudible].
And she said to me
once when I was like --
it's like you're in a
very unique position
because so many [inaudible]
folklore as an anthropologist is
to go an study the minority group.
African-American or
Lithuanian-American
or to go to other countries.
But who studies America?
Who looks at America?
And as a person of color,
with this British accent,
you can be in a position to use
that skill to be able to facilitate.
So make sure you use it wisely.
And I think back to
that because back
in Scotland, here was British brown.
I wasn't Catholic or Protestant.
So when I first got into Glasgow,
the first thing, I
was on a subway train.
And people were singing the song
hello, hello, we are the Biddy Boys.
Surrender or you'll die.
It's a sectarian song.
It's a anti-Catholic song.
But the thing I saw at everybody on
that train was that people just kind
of accepted oh, it's them.
And no, we don't accept it.
And I think there was so much of
an attitude for 3 million people
that this is the way it is.
It's the way it's always been, and
we just have to put up with it.
The first approach really
was going out collecting.
We did a lot of collecting.
And I say some were
unorthodox ways of collecting.
Going to the Glasgow
Barras [phonetic] markets.
Going behind the counter and
picking up a sectarian merchandise
that the guy was selling, but he
would only sell it as like a scarf.
A Celtic scarf that
God's chosen people.
Or stuff that would be the
sectarian-related about the IRA
or the UDA, the paramilitaries.
We collected these objects,
but we also looked at song.
And some of the songs, the
ballads, that were used for such
as Greenfields of France, which is
an Irish song, an Irish folk song.
Talks about the Great War,
not about the troubles.
So what it does do, is a song
that unites different communities
that live across divisions.
But many people not realizing that
it's sung in the pubs and the homes
and the social gatherings.
It's a song that unites cultural
difference by a number of series
of collections, but I'd say a big,
big part of that was
city leadership.
Because what happened
was Jack McConnell,
who was the First Minister at
the time, he was Protestant,
married to a Catholic, Bridget
McConnell, who was the leader
of the Cultural and Leisure
Services for Glasgow.
I knew that sectarianism
was becoming a hot topic.
People didn't know how to tackle it.
My own institution was 80%
Roman Catholic in a city
with 26% Roman Catholics,
six percent of Scotland.
But it's historic so it's seen
as a sectarian institution.
So how do we -- but I knew it was
becoming a topic that was going
to get funding as well
and political support.
So it was about working with
the Scottish government,
building those connections, and
also [inaudible] leadership.
Mark O'Neill , who was
the head of the museums
and gallery service
was a forward figure.
He was an Irish man, so
he was a forward thinker.
And he employed many of us as
community workers, social workers,
education specialists, to get
higher pay in the museum service
because we understood the
connection between people and how
to make a partnership
of health organization,
community organizations.
So rather than having just
14 museums, 46 libraries,
we also had partnerships with
health centers, community centers.
So it was a much more
strategic approach.
When you have that backing,
you allow it to take risks.
Many of the different ways
was setting up a program.
I talk about my own first
experience was setting
up a program called Bigot
Busters, a very simple catchy name,
marketing and good branding.
Send it out there and it was really
to enable teachers in Scotland
to understand how to pack a
new curriculum [inaudible] have
citizenship, what that meant.
And so I'll reach out to
Protestant-based schools,
nondenominational schools,
like the Protestant schools,
and Catholic-based schools.
And the folklore clubs,
Rangers and Celtic.
As well as educate -- and
work with them in a way
that would take objects out to
those schools and get projects
where they would come
as part of a visit.
Every school had to kind
of pay for their visit.
But if you were a Catholic school
and Protestant school and you came
in a joint visit, your
trip was free.
Supported by the local government.
To encourage that,
foster that healing.
[Inaudible] was a very simple school
space program, but then expanded
into a way where Ulster
Museum and some
of the Northern Ireland counterparts
would invite me or some colleagues
to go over to Northern Ireland
but as part of the peace
and reconciliation
process [inaudible] money.
They had funding to
support the peace process,
so we would contact leaders
in the political departments
in Northern Ireland as a
Northern Ireland assembly
and community relation
and Ulster Museum
that would put together groups that
included ex-paramilitary groups.
IRA, UDA, police officials, army
officers, government officials.
The Ulster Unionist Party.
The SDLP. To come as a
part of a group to come
across the water to Glasgow.
Because when they do that,
they have something in common.
Their land.
You can make that kind of
space for conversation.
And with that political support,
using our museums as spaces
to facilitate conversations.
So that grew from a very simple
program like that to programs
where we unpacked --
does everyone --
everyone agree that sectarianism
need to be tackled but when it came
down to unpacking the divisions
like segregate schools.
Or a marching culture.
Then we differed.
So it was about unpacking those
things that really matter to go
into a deeper level, and
people sharing their stories.
One such example.
And I'm going to tell one
example where as a member of --
one of those people that came over
was a member of the Orange Order.
If you know anything about the
Oranges, the Protestant fraternity,
is seen as the 90,000 people walked,
marched through the city of Glasgow
and it's seen as a
Protestant victory.
And they're not liked
by many people.
But one member of the Orange
Order came in that group.
And we had Roman Catholic members.
We had people from the
churches and faith.
And he said to participate in
that one day of dialogue we had
to [inaudible] that he's doing it
because Jesus is important to him
and teaches him to
love his neighbor.
His faith is important to him
but when he goes back home,
his entire church and community
are going to disown him.
I think that -- I mean
I think that was brave.
And also because he was able to tell
that in a way that was it authentic.
It was true.
It was his personal
experience was about to happen.
But he did it because of his
brothers and sisters he sees.
So there was those kind of
more closed-off programs.
There were also things like we
brought in an exhibition that looked
at 21st images of the
KKK in the United States.
And we brought that to Scotland.
One of the reasons being to let
Scotland remember what you sent
out because it was founded by
you know that Scottish influence.
Bring it back to Scotland.
At the same time, in 2005
was the cartoon images
of the Prophet Mohammed that came
out in the Danish news cartoons.
I was contacted by a Danish school.
We said well how, you
know, how are we going --
and Britain actually banned
those images to be displayed.
But city leadership said if you
want to do a discussion on this,
you can use those images.
You know, we can bring it out,
even though Tony Blair
banned the use of them.
So we facilitated a space where
local Muslims and Iraqi Muslims,
refugee Muslims, could
talk to those students
and discuss what those
images meant for them
as Muslims, as Danish young people.
And looked at the exhibition of KKK.
What can happen when people
use, promote ideas of race,
racial ideology or
racism through religion.
There was many levels of that,
and there was obviously much,
much larger kind of programs
where young kids were empowered
to write five-point action plans
on how to tackle sectarianism
between Catholics and
Protestant schools.
And the kids became the kind of
committee and we would support them
to write a letter and send
it to the First Minister
of Scotland demanding a response.
Many, many [inaudible], but I
think a lot of that process was
because culture and art
is seen at the forefront
of each can change our societies.
One example being in Northern
Ireland, where my colleagues,
they have in their
collections poetry.
This big, written by Bobby Sands,
the IRA hunger striker when he was
in Long Kesh Prison
called Poetic Justice.
It was sneaked out of the museum in
a [inaudible] up someone's backside,
but eventually got
out of the museum.
It stayed in the museum's
collections for so many,
many years until the peace
process was kicked in in Derry.
And what they could do, they
could then put it on display.
And then they can invite the
community from both sides to come
and interpret those objects.
Not just that one but other --
there was a steering wheel
that had a bullet through it.
There were the dust bin, trash
can, that were used as signals.
In communities, such as Derry, when
the British army were coming in
and women would clamp
on the trash cans.
And the men would go through
the underground tunnels
and escape out to the mountains.
By bringing in communities
to interpret these exhibitions
at a time where we can.
The tensions are still there
but there weren't violence.
Then that was a good time to
bring those discussions in.
So these are kind of
examples of many, many others.
But I think very much -- but
having a very leftist, I guess,
Glasgow's very -- I think, very
progressive and has a good vision.
They celebrate every year for the
Douglas' birthday and Mandela Day
and many, many other components.
Go to Glasgow, you'll
see what I mean.
But really taking social issues
as the starting point
rather than the object.
A long answer.
I'm sorry.
>> It's worth it [inaudible].
>> [Inaudible].
Before you went to graduate
school in folklore in Chapel Hill,
how did academic study in
folklore influence your work?
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Do you know,
I have to be really, really honest.
When I, when I was doing work in the
National Museum of Scotland I came
in as a teacher, as an artist.
I spent seven -- I would
work seven days a week.
I would go and work in communities
and I had a museum's
master background
and an education background
and an art degree.
And I've lived in Spain.
When I came in and then when
I'd done all this work after 10,
12 years, they said apply for
the Rotary Peace Fellowship.
And it's by chance that the
Rotary Peace Program was based
at Duke in UNC.
But when my person that was
inviting me to come and be part
of the scholarship-based program,
because we think you should be
in the folklore department.
And I said what is folklore?
And I actually didn't know.
I couldn't define.
I always thought that
term, oh it's story tale.
It's stories.
You know? And I had that kind of --
but now looking at
obviously folklore
from a much more deeper
perspective and looking
at when people say it is [inaudible]
because of the many diverse ways
that we tell our stories is
telling the world who we are.
Where we come from.
Wherever that is your kilt.
Wherever is your food.
Your proverb.
Your -- however we put it out there
is telling the world who we are.
Where we come from.
And I would say that a lot
of the -- it didn't as much.
I did a lot of public reading.
I read in the daily
newspaper, you know, and I --
a part [inaudible] maybe
more my museum theory.
Or museum background
on interpretation
and those sort of components.
>> How long are you
going to be here?
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: I'll be
here till Friday or Saturday.
>> Great. Then I'd
like to invite you
to our storytelling
session on Capitol Hill.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
On Capitol Hill?
>> Tomorrow evening, so I
brought the information.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Are you Karen?
Is your name Karen?
>> No --
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: You're Karen.
Your daughter said I must meet you.
Okay.
>> Yeah, so we have a
-- it's five years old
where every month we tell stories.
We have seen and people
get together.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
And that's invited
by open invitation to people.
>> Oh yeah, [inaudible]
at the center,
at our community center
on Capitol Hill.
At the corner store.
And on Saturday morning,
the children have their
storytelling happy hour
because we try to encourage.
I'm the liaison for Washington
from National Storytelling Network.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Okay.
Perfect.
>> Yeah.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
Excellent [inaudible].
That's very good.
That'll be great.
Last time I was in Capitol
Hill I was doing poetry
for an anti-fracking demonstration.
So it's a great place
-- great platform.
So tomorrow at in the evening.
Okay. Perfect.
Thank you so much.
>> And for the rest of us,
what time does it start?
>> At seven to eight and you
have wine and cheese [inaudible].
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
I like wine and cheese.
[ Laughter ]
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I wanted you to talk a little bit
about your experiences [inaudible].
How are you with your
vision and ideas
about storytelling how
Jonesborough is not all
that [inaudible], I
don't think probable.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Well,
I think it's -- I mean.
I don't want to get into US politics
[inaudible] but I mean I'm --
I'm a brown dude from Europe.
I'm obviously -- you know I've come
from a different mental-political
[inaudible],
but I think it is progressive.
In the sense that there are
people there, there's a belief
that the arts are important.
They've invested in
the arts as a catalyst.
We talk about as cultural
trend, creative place-making.
What [inaudible] been doing for 44
years because arts is a catalyst
that is grown the community,
provides jobs,
supports an economic impact of
$7.6 million for the local region.
That's a pretty good creative
place-making case study.
All right?
I think it's progressive also
because this history of progression
because [inaudible] at
the birthplace right next
to our building is the
birthplace of the emancipator,
America's first abolitionist
newspaper.
Which I knew about in my work
back in Scotland, and here it is.
There's a history of various
different types of progressions.
You know obviously the way
[inaudible] politics are seen today
is various ways of looking at it.
But there's a very strong
connection to values
and community and connection.
And I think that's very important,
and I think there's a
very good welcome of that.
My work in the storytelling center.
When I first started, I
think there was a reach
out to the National Storytelling
Network that were invited
to ask what type of person
would you like to see.
Now Jimmy Neil Smith, my
predecessor and my friend,
had founded the organization for
and retired in 2010 for 40 years.
And they said they want
someone to put the international
into the International
Storytelling Center.
They want someone younger.
They want a folklorist.
Well they got that.
You know, they got a
slam poet, too, you know.
And so where I see it is I'm not
a US citizen, so the way I think
about -- we have an
international responsibility.
[Inaudible] every US
organization for my time,
but I do that so we can do pro-bono
work in Rwanda, in South Africa.
In the Middle East.
Because that's part of our
international responsibility.
We have to share our resources.
The sort of the work that
we try and do is to build,
before the storytelling
center, I didn't know about it.
So we have to build a type
of strategic partnership,
so people can be engaged.
And I think that's ultimately is
about when we can harness the power
of story for a young person
to cultivate how to use story
in various different ways.
So building partnerships with
like the Google Cultural Institute
so we can create video
footage that goes
out to 14 million social
media followers.
To reestablish work
with UN education.
Put peace at the heart
of what we're doing.
Put community building at the
heart of what we're doing.
And form the right
type of partnerships.
The right type of partnerships
are when we're invited to go
to Charleston, South Carolina,
to work with the victims
and families following the massacre
that took place in Charleston.
The right types of partnerships
is the Ferguson commission,
using stories to help promote
healing and reconciliation.
Working in Baltimore.
Working with communities
on the grassroots level.
Our trying to use story to honor
their ancestors, native cultures,
African-American ancestry.
To help bring more balance
to America's story by working
with partnerships that can help
America to understand itself
from the diverse ways that
we can see one another.
Those are very strategic.
It's also about looking beyond
the art sector and working
with the international
development sector.
I work a lot with the peacebuilding,
Alliance of Peacebuilding,
and the way -- because we want to
put storytelling as both a folk
and traditional art form
and the many different ways.
But put it at the heart
of peacebuilding work.
So we're doing programs here
in DC and with the Alliance
for Peacebuilding this week, looking
at story as a counterterrorism tool.
And building global strategies
with civil society organization
to empower and use [inaudible] as
a creative tool at the beginning
of conflict prevention and not
part of conflict resolution.
[Inaudible] arts and creativity
and culture and at the forefront
of our thinking when we're building
strategic partnerships [inaudible]
across the world, so
we can be smarter.
We can draw from our
traditions to alleviate conflict
and prevent conflict from happening.
So we're doing a lot
of that type of work.
And obviously reaching
out in Silicon Valley
for those investors [inaudible]
I'm reaching out to Silicon Valley.
I'm reaching out to Ford Foundation.
And inviting people with lots of
money to come and support what we do
because you can't do
what we do without money.
So that's partly that.
But you have to look at -- and you
know corporate investments as well.
So there's a lot of that and
growing the festival in a way
to make it meaningful for
diverse ways of looking
at ways stories can connect.
So we invite slam poets.
We invite the founders of slam.
We invited Piper Kerman to
offer Orange is the New Black.
Many older people won't know
her, but many millennials do
because she's a hit, around
50 million viewers on Netflix.
So you invite her to come and tell
her personal story about what it was
like to be incarcerated for a year.
Through an LGBT [inaudible]-based
stories, 9/11-based stories.
And invite and making sure
that diversity and equality is
at the forefront on the front
stages and never on the fringes.
Diversity, equality, is at
the heart, at the forefront
and very visually out there
because it sends a signal
that if you're a National
Storytelling Festival you have
to represent the nation, you know.
And not just the Appalachian region.
A lot of those type of work.
>> Hi Kiran --
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Hey Todd --
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> And the National
Storytelling Center,
we've been partners for a long time.
And I think that you're one of our
major partners and I just wondered
if in your kind of idealistic
world, what would the --
how would that partnership look?
How would we help to
reflect the vision
that you're bringing to the center?
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
Thanks Todd [laughter].
I mean I see it as a -- you
know, it's a great relationship.
And it's kind of like we're growing
together, and we're growing in line
with the way the storytelling
movements growing, too.
I see it as a way that I'd love
to be able to find the grant
to digitize the entire collection.
When we digitize that
entire collection.
The way I see it is that
we can help tell the story
of the storytelling movement.
Because if you've got all these
collections from Ray Hicks
and Kathryn Windrom [assumed
spelling] and Jackie Torrance
and you know going
back to Guy Carawan
and Doc McConnell, [inaudible].
Pete Seeger.
They're in your collections.
Once we digitize that
collections we can create ways
to make public access.
Every kid in America
can get connected
to the diverse [inaudible] the
way the storytelling movement has
changed, from [inaudible]
personal narrative now.
You could enter [inaudible]
and all these great programs,
then we can create public programs.
And that's my interest is to
really digitize those collections,
but I also want to look at the
way these collections can be used
in ways to promote things like how
do we grapple with climate change?
Because I think in a lot of
those stories that we have,
because they have so many
of the folktales that draw
from many different traditions
and draw from diaspora traditions.
That a lot of these have content
and wisdom that we can apply
to when we're trying to grapple
with migration and issues
and climate change and
conflict and war and a lot
of the international
peacekeeping world.
Peace and [inaudible] to
connect with this ancient wisdom.
Because they are the
[inaudible] of our world.
So I'd love to see that more
-- that type of collaboration.
Obviously the commitment to
public access is really important.
And if this Google
partnership happens --
I don't know if Nicky's here.
But this Google partner
-- hello Nicky.
So with the Google
partnership, if that happens,
then obviously we can help
to digitize part of
the print collection.
Which that's a great start
because we can eventually make
this material more [inaudible].
And obviously I think you know
drawing from the expertise
of what you guys have and
allowing more people to get access,
not just here but also
across the world,
so people can see the
story behind the story.
What makes up America.
Thank you very much.
Yeah. Up to you, Nancy.
>> I'd like to take one
or two more questions.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Sure.
I'll take one [inaudible].
>> I'm kind of an amateur
learning about storytelling.
But I was just wondering
if you have any suggestions
of what the average person can
do in their day-to-day life
to promote connection and
engagement and what they can do
with their personal story.
In a simple way.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Absolutely.
I think that's a good question.
I think it's really important.
I think sometimes when I
do storytelling workshops,
sometimes I don't start off
the question what's your story
because suddenly you just
get this kind of blank.
And you feel like you
have to be really good.
So you start off with a question.
What's the moment that
you start to think
about the world in a different way?
What was the happiest
part of your life?
When you go back home at
Thanksgiving or you're
with your loved one, you don't
-- you become the storyteller.
And so going back to the moments
that are important to you.
And I always do a little
meditation, actually.
Close your eyes.
In your mind go back to when you
were young and paint a picture
of what it looks like in standing in
front of your house, of your home.
Start describing the sky and if it
was words or [inaudible] taste it.
Start going back into
your imagination
because all the content is there.
And [inaudible] sometimes just
start with those single moments.
The moment that you --
that's important to you that
changed the way that you might think
about a certain thing in life.
Or experience.
Or a person you met.
Or an event.
And use that as a starting place and
then you start, just start exploring
that and use that as a starting
place to start writing your story.
And don't worry about it being all
[inaudible] amazingly presented.
You know beginning, middle,
and end type of ideas.
Just start and see
where it takes you.
Other than that, there's
a toolkit you can use.
And I got a toolkit called Telling
Stories that Matter on our website,
International Storytelling Center.
That looks at not just
how you tell your own --
how you can cultivate your own
story but how you can use it
in community-building work.
How you can collect story
with some ethics in them.
About the importance of when you're
collecting stories you know some
of those ethical rules I
think you should be following.
I hope that was helpful.
I've got two -- sorry.
Bill and -- yeah.
>> Well I'll give you a
chance to tell a story here.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Oh no.
>> [Inaudible].
Earlier on you mentioned bringing
two gangs together in Glasgow
and the first bringing them
together resulted in a fight.
And you tried it again, and
a fight didn't take place.
So what did you do to keep the fight
from breaking out in the first time
and what did you hope to achieve?
>> Kiran Singh Sirah:
Well [inaudible].
Yeah. I mean the idea is
because what happened.
And Glasgow's very territorial,
and it's pocketed with Catholics
and Protestants, Catholics
and Protestants.
But [inaudible] and the reason we --
the reason we wanted to do
that together is because a lot
of these young groups are
age 12 and 13 years old.
They would die for their friends.
That family unit that they create
in those groups, territorial.
You could be GYT, Govannhill
Young Team, and you'd mark your --
but you won't go across the street
because that's a [inaudible].
But inside those groups,
you've got Ranger's supporters
and Celtic support, the
Catholics and Protestants.
So it's kind of like the time
where we can unpack
what sectarianism means
in the city before they become --
they start going to football games
with the dad and to different pubs.
So the idea was to unpack that
friendship and unpack when you hear
that -- using those -- what
does that mean for them?
So the reason why it kicked off
as a fight in the first time was
because we didn't have enough of us.
We didn't have enough of
the social work staff.
There was too many in the group, and
that something happened between one
of those young people that it --
there was a lot of tension inside
that young man, that it
was already in a conflict.
The next time we do it, I sought
the advice from social workers.
They're the specialists when
it comes to those young --
they understood their lives.
They could describe what was
going on and what was going on.
We reduced the number of the group
and we increased some social work
and we just planned it better.
And we did it again.
One of the things that we did is
the Restorative Justice Program,
was a program where if a young
person commits a first-time offense.
Usually what they do, I asked
the police officer what do you do
[inaudible] get them to paint
the train station or whatever.
Just a community service.
I said well send them to me.
So they started coming to
me in the museum and working
on three months' residencies
with artists.
I got artists, textile artists,
poets, and all sorts of people.
And they thought they're
being punished,
but what they're doing is
creating an exhibition.
And some of these exhibitions
would have GYT, the vernacular form
of graffiti you find in Glasgow
and turn it anti-sectarian
or anti-racism.
Messages. And we've displayed
that alongside Salvador Dali's
Christ of St John of the Cross.
The most famous painting
in Scotland.
When a young person sees their
artwork displayed alongside this
most important painting, they --
well, it's basically
saying society loves you.
Society cares about you
and your voice matters.
When you start to cultivate your own
story, you start to love yourself.
And when you love yourself,
you can love others.
So those were types of programs
that we did, but it was very much
about one-to-one small group
work for a lot of that.
It was very intense.
But bringing in other specialists.
You were specialists in one area
but others recognize other
people have specialisms
and join from the specialism.
I'm sorry [inaudible].
Well yeah.
Last one and then yeah.
Just -- yes?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: My kilt?
>> Yeah [laughter].
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Thank you.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> And I heard you talking about
Africans, people of African descent
from all over diaspora but I didn't
hear very much about Africans --
diasporic Africans here, from here.
You know? Those who had come --
whose people had come through
the enslaved experience.
And I just wondered is the African
Voices Exhibit included those voices
as well?
Because often we are
considered not diasporic.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: No.
Yeah.
>> I don't know where they
think we came from but --
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Yeah.
It did in the sense -- but maybe
because such a large portion
of the black population
in Britain is Caribbean.
So Guyana and Jamaica and
all the Caribbean islands.
So a very large population
in Scotland, across Scotland,
is the Caribbean, African-Caribbean
population.
So we did Beth Ford who
was African-Caribbean.
But during that time, there was
many, many projects that we did.
And we looked at transatlantic
slavery.
We looked at the products
that came into Glasgow.
We looked at the tobacco lords
because most of tobacco that came
from this part of the world,
in Americas, came to Glasgow.
Glasgow made its fortune
distributed across Europe
with other products you know coming
into Liverpool, [inaudible]
or Bristol.
But part of that was also
looking up say Robert Burns.
When Robert Burns was asked
to be a plantation owner
and came [inaudible] refused
and wrote the Slave's Lament.
So we looked at Scottish heroes but
looked at it from that perspective.
So invited people and artists
to interpret that stuff
on various different perspectives.
But we did look at the life
of you know leading abolitionists
like Frederick Douglass.
You know, there was some loose
connections with Boston and things
like that, but it was primarily
looking at within Britain
and those British colonies.
But I agree.
I don't think there
was probably as much
as [inaudible] the
United States [inaudible].
Yeah. Next time.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Kiran Singh Sirah: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.